call it a pandemic Paradox over the past
two years food insecurity has been on
the rise but so has the amount of food
being wasted crops headed from Farm to
Table have been rotting in fields due to
disrupted demand but some young people
had a vision to shortcut the supply
chain and directly link those food
products with the people who need them
the most from Los Angeles Catherine
Herridge has the story
Los Angeles Warehouse they're delivering
change there's not a crisis of Security
in the United States there's a crisis of
indifference James Kenneth and Aiden
Riley like to tackle tough projects
they've been at it since middle school
part of the reason the Friendship stayed
really strong is because we always like
to do projects together and it was
always annoying our parents but then as
we got older it became something that
actually like was fruitful for us
figuring out what it is we liked and
what we wanted to do in the world
launched during the pandemic farmlink is
their most ambitious project yet we're
growing enough food to feed every person
in this country and honestly every
person on the planet farming is a
student-led movement with the goal of
connecting Farms all around the country
that have surplus food to food banks
that need it one of their first farmers
Shea Myers asked for help on Tick Tock I
wanted to show you one of the
ramifications of coven 19. with
restaurant demand down thousands of
pounds of onions piled up why are you
dumping why are you dumping why are you
don't not donating the supply chain is
broken guys if we can't get under the
city we still have to throw them away
instead the farmlink team connected
Myers to food banks who needed his
produce the look them up found his phone
number hey you know I hear you're having
some trouble moving onions I would love
to help did the project take off during
the pandemic once we got that early
delivery of onions from Shea Myers the
photos and videos of that circulated
very quickly and literally hundreds of
emails from people around the country
asking how they could help for those who
work the land farmlink's Ben Collier
told us it's a heartbreaking dilemma
farmers are paying 80 a ton in some
instances to throw away food Quality
Foods like these lemons the skin is
dried and papayas it got rejected
because it has some spots end up in
landfills creating greenhouse gases what
do you want people to know about the
environmental impact it plays the one of
the most significant roles in climate
change it ends up rotting and producing
methane the food waste was a country it
would be the third largest emitter of
greenhouse gas emissions our job here at
the farmlink project is to create a
bridge between that mountain of food and
that tremendous need any more food over
there demand is constant with Rising
grocery prices and double lines at food
banks we still need that fresh food and
the health benefits that it gives now
operating in 48 states this month
farmlink hit a milestone 50 million
pounds of produce recovered the
equivalent of 42 million meals it's
satisfying to see how proud farmers are
to be able to do that they take a lot of
pride in their work in feeding other
people the last thing they want is for
their food to go to waste in March the
Congressional Medal of Honor Society
recognized kanath and Riley with a
public service award and last month they
hit the Forbes 30 under 30. now they
want to expand a paid fellowship program
if designing the future of our food
system it needs to be people from all
walks of life and not just people who
have the luxury to donate that time
during the week these friends saw a
solution where others saw blocks I've
never been a part of something that felt
more important for CBS Saturday morning
Catherine Herridge Los Angeles
so important good for them so happy I
just want to repeat that 48 states right
50 million pounds of produce recovered
that's the equivalent of 42 million
meals solving two problems right once
great work guys yeah good job